let's talk about something which is
going on right now and that is the
election between bush and Dukakis it
seemed to me from the outset when the
Republicans Jorge Moritz chose Bush that
good Lord if there's anybody it was ever
vulnerable to attack it was George Bush
from so many fields but we don't see it
can you tick off some of these things
that the Democrats could depend on
George Bush it's you know I think it's
almost the crime of the century that
Bush's true past does not come out the
man is so thoroughly tainted with so
many different scandals and and
world-scale world-scale wrongdoing that
it's a mind boggling that he's still
standing I let alone on his way to the
White House Bush in 1980s I know many
people watching know was involved with
perhaps the most heinous and cynical
manipulation of American electoral
politics on record which is the October
Surprise scenario in 1980 there were 57
hostages being held in Tehran by the
Ayatollah and Carter was in the White
House and all the polls showed that if
Carter got the hostages out within two
weeks of the election that he would win
reelection and that if they didn't get
out that his general impotence would
reflect badly and that the and that
Reagan would win and in early October I
remember this specifically and it's been
widely reported Carter's dealings with
the Iranians seem to be bearing fruit
and it appeared that a deal was going to
be struck in that the reign that the
hostages were going to get out and that
Carter would probably win the election
but suddenly the negotiations broke down
and the hostages did not get out and in
fact they were released as you'll
remember well remember precisely as
Ronald Reagan was taking the oath of
office now let's see
to me and my paranoia that seemed hey
wait well then soon thereafter soon
thereafter the Reagan administration
started sending large quantities of arms
to Tehran by way of Israel and it's
known that the first shipments began as
early as March of 1981 one of the planes
crashed on its way from Tel Aviv to
Tehran in the summer of 1981 and the
contents of the of the the plane were
confirmed to be arms from from the US
and of course the Israelis could never
shipped any arms to Tehran without the
approval of the Reagan administration so
what happened you have three basic
elements here and then you know what
I've been working for months to get the
major media to take the story and deal
with it in a big way and all the
electronic journalists know about all
the printer noises know about it's no
secret except to the American public as
a whole even the New York Times which is
supposed to be the newspaper of record
and the university hasn't touched it now
and yet this is something which water
gates like you know what not like a
mosquito bite you know staying in an
elephant's butt yeah it's nothing
compared to this this is a a pre cool in
a way well it's actually a treat it's
actually a capital offense I mean I'm
gonna harm an opponent of capital
punishment but I suppose in this case I
could be persuaded to make an exception
what what it boils down to is this you
know there's a lot of talk about the sky
brenneke and rough in Colorado who
allegedly were involved in flying bush
over there to make the deal and then
there was a bani-sadr
the president was President of Iran at
the time who made the initial accusation
in media that this had happened and all
the guys are the media people are saying
well there's no smoking gun and you know
just like there was no smoking gun with
whether Reagan knew or not that the
profits from the Iranian arms deal we're
going to feed the Contras well it
doesn't matter if there was a smoking
gun or not you have a basic situation
here there are only three of in which
there are only three scenarios
explaining why the hostage
did not get out after Carter got the
deal going why they were then released
precisely as Reagan was being
inaugurated and then why American arms
started going to Iran
now the first explanation we had from
that in West rias liberal George Will
was that the reason the hostages were
let out when Reagan was being nominee
was because Reagan threatened the Neukom
with drop nuclear weapons well you know
this is ridiculously the Iranians never
would have taken a felt like that
seriously and certainly we wouldn't have
started been sending them guns after
Reagan's inauguration if we had just
threatened to drop nuclear weapons on
them second explanation was that the
Iranians hated Jimmy Carter so much they
want to do anything they could to hurt
him well if they hit him that much why
were they negotiating with him in the
first place and the Iranians may be
driven by many emotions but they were
involved in a war at the time with Iraq
and these hostages were clearly legal
tender I mean no or illegal tender I
mean they were worth quite a bit and the
Iranians never would have just thrown
them away in an empty gesture they would
they would have gotten something in
exchange
so really logically looking at the
bigger picture the only explanation that
makes any sense at all is that the
Reagan Bush campaign went in and
intervened and negotiations the Cardo
was having with the Iranians which is a
treasonable offense and arranged that
the hostages be kept until after the
election not merely until after the
election but until the precise moment
that Jimmy that Ronald Reagan was being
inaugurated and bani-sadr who was
president of Iran at the time has said
that he felt the reason that they did
that was so that it would give a boost
to the Reagan Revolution when
came into power now there what it's well
known there was an October Surprise
committee in the reagan-bush campaign
apparatus it was headed by Richard Alan
Allen's boss who was running the
campaign was William Casey who became
head of the CIA and it doesn't take any
great genius to understand that these
people were capable of this kind of deal
particularly when we find out later that
the Contras have been nose deep and
dealing drugs all these years and Bush
was head of the CIA when Orlando
Letelier was murdered in downtown
Washington this kind of stuff these
people were quite capable of the biggest
mystery to me at this point is why the
Dukakis campaign steered away from the
story altogether
it's also curious to me with the media
because Jimmy Carter was on Larry King
show did you see that yeah see I didn't
see it but I read the transcripts and
Carter said that he knew about it the
Carter said well he said that basically
he was willing to tell what he knew
about it
if Dukakis would ask him and Dukakis
never asked him but he acknowledged that
he was aware that it was going on when
he was still in office yeah he had heard
rumors and that he but you know there's
a difference seems to be a different
standard of proof here I mean you know
they hounded Gary Hart into oblivion for
being having his picture taken with
Donna rice I mean according to this
standard of proof they would have had
you know the media has not even put the
story out the electronic media but they
were certainly willing to put the story
out about Gary Hart now what was the
smoking gun in that situation I mean did
they have action you would think that
they would have needed an action video
of Jerry and Donna going at it in order
to break the story her dripping dripping
gun and she smoking gun well you said
that but in this case you know I've
talked to producers at CBS and all the
other networks and they simply would not
go with the story they even have there's
even a guy in Colorado
brenneke who has testified to a court to
the federal court that he has evidence
that Bush himself flew to Paris to make
this deal and the media still won't deal
with it now one interesting thing is
that a lawsuit has been filed on behalf
of 13 of the actual hostages who were
held in a tehran at the time charging
now they've been suing all along ever
since they got out for very compensation
but now they're charging that they're
actually charging the reagan-bush
campaign with having deliberately
detained them longer than necessary in
order to win the election and we're very
interesting to see I don't have much
faith in the legal system in terms of
getting this story further down the pike
but I will say this that you know we're
talking just prior to the election if
Bush does win which looks like it's a
likelihood now although less likely than
the media has been willing to has been
putting out but if we have a president
Bush hard to even say that and the
economy does go down I think that you'll
have enough anger out there that some of
this stuff will come out now but I have
been deeply impressed by the ability of
the Reagan people to suppress major news
stories even when their congressional
hearings going on you know the media has
stopped covering for congressional
hearings before Reagan came in it was
standard that there would be segments on
the evening news about the various
congressional hearings going on that has
disappeared in the age of Reagan and
there has been a decision made that
instead of covering congressional
hearings the you know basic trivia will
find its way onto the meaning of the
national news is just it's hardly even a
cut above the local ambulance-chasing
Man Bites Dog stories here on the local
news well it's worse than I mean that
that's better at least that is has some
relations with reality some on the on
the media on the TV networks
particularly we just see the
disinformation of the Reagan
administration night after night
yeah it's amazing and but they eat
throughout those whole months of the
iran-contra hearings they never ever got
to discuss the the fact that the Contras
are drug dealers and it was the only
person that mentioned it ironically was
orrin hatch the right-wing senator from
Utah who basically with Howie North up
there said you know Oh gracious exalted
Patriot we've heard these ugly rumors
about the Contras dealing drugs they're
not true are they and I always said no
and that was the end of it but you know
months of hearings go by and nobody
brings up the idea the fact that the
Contras are drug dealers so it's a
similar situation with the October
Surprise I've been pushing this I've
been pushing the story for months
basically since I'm a writer right I try
and get op eds published I would send
the op-ed to I sent the OP that I wrote
to some papers in Miami and they told me
oh that's old news it had been covered
to a certain extent in the Miami Miami
Herald yes they'd been done I sent the
same op-ed to the guy in the Minneapolis
paper and he had never heard the story
at all and I had a similar mixed
response all over the country now I did
have the op-ed that I wrote published in
the Los Angeles Herald examiner the
morning of the second debate when
Dukakis was asked that important
presidential question what he would do
if his ripe wife was raped and murdered
this has quite a bearing on how one
conducts the office of the presidency
but and he nobody brought it up it was
in the the LA Herald examiner is the
second biggest paper in LA it was right
there on the out page of the page that
morning the entire American media was in
LA at nobody asks a question and Dukakis
I have to play a tremendous amount of
blame on Dukakis himself
I mean you do nominate a candidate
precisely to bring these things up and
this guy for whatever reason I cannot
imagine decided that he was I he was not
going to deal with this stuff at all I
mean the closest he got was to Noriega
it's a disgusting again Noriega is the
barely the tip of the iceberg of what
what these Bush people have been willing
to do well also the fact uh somebody was
telling me the other day the thing that
was somebody who worked in the White
House are close there and they said that
Bush's office is right actually right
next door to Oliver North's office well
are we all right down there and so as a
result it was so easy for Donald Gregg
to to supervise the running of the
narcotics trade sure how is the vice
president's office can you imagine that
but it makes sense you know the black
activists have always talked to the
federal government the right wing has
always wanted drugs in the ghettos I
mean they they want these people they
want the underclass drugged-out the
exhibit the emergence of crack it is no
coincidence in this in this point time I
mean the great social legacy of the
Reagan administration is a permanent
underclass that's drugged out uneducated
homeless and hopeless and that they want
the creation of that so you have this
amazing hypocrisy going on and these
people talking about suppressing the
drug trade and at the same time
promoting it because they don't want
these people voting they don't want them
active they don't want them reading and
getting politically involved and and
it's it's you know George Orwell talked
about the same kind of stuffy Marx
talked about it in a way you know
religion is the opiate of the people now
opium is the opiate of the people I mean
at the bottom are in OPM's in religion
system and so in a certain sense and
it's government promoted and the
astounding thing is that they've been
able to get away with it now you know
there is an undercurrent out there not a
people do know about this October
surprise no one I've ever told you need
there's a fair amount of knowledge about
it no one I've ever mentioned it to the
the scenario to has doubted that it
could have happened and a sooner or
later I do believe it will come out the
question is in what form and what impact
will
and now I think it's going to depend I
hate to say it on the economy if the
economy goes down people get really
angry all this stuff will come out but
I'm not wishing for that time that way I
wish we had a strong enough pure
Democratic urge that would just come out
on its own you know there's another
story which new caucus has never come
out with a mention and that was the
famous interview was George Bush had
with the LA Times back in 1980 in which
he said oh yeah we could have World War
3 survivability that's why we
survivability of command and control was
always bushes yeah we'd have our natural
resources we'd have survivability of
command and control meaning the people
in the power structure who runs things
we'd lose 50 million people but heck we
could inflict more damage on the
Russians and they could on us yet
nothing is said whatsoever about no
hasn't been brought up at all and it
will be brought up I think over time but
with American public's where we've been
let down by the Democratic nominee I
mean Dukakis won the nomination
basically because he had the best
fundraisers and that speaks very ill for
the for the process as a whole and it's
just going to have to be shows like this
and people just banging away and
wherever we can to get the stuff out and
sooner or later you have to hope it'll
come out now and you know if people have
any doubt at all about the the gravity
of this secum end they think back to the
Lusitania the Lusitania was a British
luxury liner and I talk about it in my
book Harvey Washington's history of the
US which covers 1860 to 1920 and the
American public really did not want the
u.s. to go into World War one was very
unpopular but in 1915 the Germans sank a
luxury liner was a British ship going
from the u.s. from New York to London it
was carrying all these passengers
including 120 Americans and at the time
Great Britain and Germany were at war
with each other and one of the rules of
war was that you were allowed the sink
ships that were carrying weapons and
that was just basically
so the Germans sank the Lusitania and
they claimed that it was for weapons and
the British said there were no weapons
and 120 Americans died and Woodrow
Wilson seized on this as a big you know
thing for beating that the Germans in
this tremendous racist outbreak came
everybody hated the Germans except the
German Americans and the radical labor
movement which smelled something smelled
fishy to them and they did not want
because they knew if we run into World
War 1 that there would be tremendous
repression and they great skewing of
interest in in the issues at home which
were economic democracy and control of
the factories and redistribution of
wealth as opposed to going into a war so
but Wilson of course use this and the
people got into the preparedness
movement and started building weapons
and then in 1916 Wilson ran as a peace
candidate in 1917 he got us into the war
sounds like LBJ don't oh yeah and I was
all based a lot it was based on the
emotional response to the 120 Americans
who died in the Lusitania well earlier
this decade with all the advances in
undersea technology guess what happened
a submarine a deep sea submarine got
down to the Lusitania guess what they
found on the Lusitania tons of weapons
that were being actually being shipped
from the u.s. to Great Britain the
United States got involved in World War
one on the basis of a complete lie and
it's it's indisputable so you know when
people ever say well I had one news
person actually say that she just
couldn't believe that people would be so
cynical as to arrange a deal to keep
hostages in Iran longer so that they
could win an election well it's happened
it's happened before we had the
Watergate story in nineteen in the
summer of 1972 I worked on a magazine
called Sundance magazine and a report we
had a reporter named Jeff girth who's a
an investigator for the New York Times
now and he had the Watergate story
covered left right center up down we had
Nixon map to all the burglars to Meyer
Lansky to them every connection you
could ever imagine to organized clear to
the Kennedy assassination the whole bit
we gave the story to George McGovern I
know he read it he wouldn't touch it you
know and then two years later of course
only about a tenth of what really was
involved with Watergate ever came out
but that was enough you know I think if
a hundred of what George Bush has been
doing ever came out that the guy would
be shot into space basically you know
that's just going to depend on us
banging away at it and keeping it
keeping it happening there's a good book
out by Marc Hertz guard a friend of mine
called on bended knee about how Reagan
has manipulated the media and it's you
know it's an infuriating story a lot of
it has to do with the economic change in
the structure of the media over the past
eight years where you know the new
centers have basically been converted
into profit centers and their their
performance is judged not on how they
cover the news which they actually used
to be but on their ratings and you know
that's why you get millions of dollars
going into these pretty faces to sit in
front of the TVs to the front of the
cameras to read nonsense basically which
passes as news and the cover of the
quality of coverage has deteriorated
enormous ly under Reagan and will
probably continue to as long as as the
TVs or stations are controlled like by
corporations like General Electric which
owns NBC and of course very shortly
after General Electric took over NBC
suddenly had a documentary about how
wonderful the nuclear power program is
in France and capital city zoning ABC
and and long it's Tish controlling CBS I
mean it's all just big money and it's
all basically aimed at ratings and the
ratings tend to aim for the lowest most
common
you see really the quality and then
these news reporters are much more
interested in their careers than then
covering the news you know and they'd
all like to win a Pulitzer Prize here
and there so everyone small you get
something breaking through the woodwork
like these stories on the weapons
facilities which my co-author Bob
Alvarez has been pushing for years and
and you'll get a reporter at a place
like The Times is really willing to push
it but something like the October
Surprise which has enormous implications
they won't touch you have to remember
that the Watergate story really only
broke because of two guys and one editor
who were willing to stick with it and
there were plenty you watch all the
President's Men which is probably
reasonable or read the book reasonable
facsimile of what went on we were very
close to not getting that story at all
and not only were we posted not getting
the story but we might never have heard
about it had not with all due respect
Walter Cronkite come out and giving it
some play on the evening news I mean
it's no longer enough for a story to
just break in the papers it has to be
covered the October Surprise story has
been raised and it's actually been dealt
with fairly thoroughly in the LA Times
and in the Boston Globe and in some
other media media around the country
media but the reason it hasn't really
become a major issue is because the
nightly news won't won't put it on and
they really you know it shouldn't be
determined do we have absolute proof or
not if it's going to go on there it's
something it's a story that should be
put in front of major the American
public to discuss is it true is it not
true but the allegations that have been
made have been so thoroughly documented
beyond at least a reasonable credibility
that it should be discussed the same
with the contradict dealings and but you
have to fault the Democrats in the long
run I mean it is the function of an
opposition party to bring this stuff up
and if the Democrats had brought it up
the media would have covered it in all
fairness to the to the media it was an
and there's no excuse late if and we can
never either we either we never nominate
another guy like Dukakis or we start a
third party that's going to deal with
this stuff properly but it's and
ultimately it really is the Democrats
responsibility to have brought this
stuff up and they have plenty of chances
in the congressional hearings I mean the
Daniel Inouye was the chairman for those
hearings and I mean of course now there
is a John Kerry's committees have been
dealing to a certain degree with the
trunk of the Contra duct dealings and
they have not gotten the coverage but
once again the Dukakis campaign had the
opportunity and could have brought it up
well even Jesse Jackson didn't yeah what
I don't understand so you know makes our
job all the tougher frankly I mean you
Altima toke these guys will hang
themselves but we waited eight years for
Reagan to hang himself and I guess there
was nothing from the neck up to hang and
what can you do I mean you know it just
got to keep at it
well it means there's more a greater
room for alternative views in the in the
media around the country yes absolutely
it's more necessary than ever the one
saving grace I think of the Reagan era
and it's probably a symptom of a
positive symptom of the problems with
the mainstream media is the rise of talk
radio in fact a number of the newspaper
coverage some of the newspaper coverage
about the October Surprise specifically
cited the proliferation of the story on
talk radio and you know I hope that is
one area of mass access media that we
people really have to be very aware of
and and to use because people do listen
and they do participate and it's there's
nothing better in addition to talking to
on a show like this to be able to sit in
a radio station and get phone calls and
go back and forth and know that a lot of
people are listening it's very important
that did that need to be protected and I
would like to say that
great danger in the coming years is not
so much I mean I think we do have a lot
of danger at the Supreme Court there but
I think that the way the First Amendment
will really be assaulted as through
libel suits what's happening is that
people are finding any excuse to sue for
both newspapers and individuals for
saying certain things and the courts are
not being quick in throwing these suits
out and that really basically curtails
people's willingness to speak I know we
had this occur in Massachusetts I've
been a referendum question to shut to
nuclear plants there and the people
promoting the referendum made a
commercial with a woman whose daughter
was stricken with leukemia at birth
living right near the plant and very
clearly you know it's a symptom of
radiation sickness and this poor baby
has gone through three years of her
whole life in chemotherapy and you know
it's just a total nightmare
and they made a commercial about it and
they were they were allocated time for
under the Fairness Doctrine what's left
of it
to put it on TV and the Boston Everson's
threatened to sue the TV stations if
they ran this commercial I mean this
poor babies ball I mean you can imagine
and the TV stations caved right in and
refused to run the commercial and so you
know that kind of stuff is going to go
on more and more if you can get a cold
of a copy of it we'll put it on okay
seems to me we've seen a trend here with
the media that the more and more control
is required on the American people and
the more and more nefarious activities
which the government and the people who
control the government got into that
there's more and more suppression of
information and of course we also know
that they have laws in the books where
they can have a military fascist
dictatorship overnight in a FEMA thing
yeah is this an accurate reading well
yeah
Oh